people really want to argue with me
about this stuff i had a guy come at me
and he's like you know what if women
start taking advantage
we got it
we'll handle it when that happens i i
love that you guys think that we have no
idea that some women are batshit crazy
we know
okay we know way more shit than you know
we see the text messages she didn't send
to you
you know
we see the ones that are too crazy to
even get to your phone
because we're the ones that put a stop
to that shit we're the ones like no no
you're not gonna kidnap his mom delete
it delete it
give me the phone just give me the phone
give it to me put the phone down that's
too many bubbles he hasn't responded in
five days give me the phone
you're not sending that you're not gonna
send an adele song with six eggplant
emojis give it to me
log out now
we know
you guys just don't know that we know
because we're in this climate where
everyone's walking on eggshells and no
one's allowed to say anything negative
about a woman or people freak out that's
not healthy we have to get back to a
place where we can call out women if
they're acting like silly gooses
and there are some silly gooses out
there does anyone have any girlfriends
that think they're feminists but they're
actually just assholes
someone's gotta say yes
but i also think we have to be patient
with women right now you gotta
understand this came out of nowhere for
thousands of years nobody cared about
our feelings nobody cared about our
opinions and like a year ago everyone
was like what do you think it was like
what the fuck
i'm sorry can you just give us one
second we were not at all prepared for
that question it's just no one has ever
asked us that before can you just give
us a minute we were just taking a selfie
with dog ears so just give us one second
we're gonna regroup and we're gonna come
right back to you with an answer bitches
huddle up right now
um
they give a shit about us all of a
sudden and we have absolutely no
practice being listened to so we need to
level the fuck up right now
some things need to change around here
first of all the rose all day shirts
have to go
just for a couple of years so we get out
of the woods on this namaste in bed it's
not a sophisticated argument no more
sassy shirts for a while uh you stop
saying totes you're 40. um
we might have to stop calling each other
hookers and whores for a while does
anyone have that girlfriend hey hooker
i actually think we need to steal from
what guys do with their nicknames
because guys build each other up with
their nicknames right what up champ
what up chief
what up boss guys give each other
promotions
in their nicknames
i make television shows i have an intern
he's 20 years old people walk in they're
like what a boss i'm like what
no i'm your boss
i'm your boss that's nobody's boss
that's my friend's nephew who was too
stupid to get a job
so i had to give him an internship
because he got a chew on his s.a.t so
that's nobody's boss
okay
[Applause]
best case scenario he will be a hooker
so let's just get this
i'm your boss
i don't like any of the nicknames my
girlfriends give me they'll be like hey
honey
hey cupcake i'm like what are you doing
you don't like it when guys call you
that let's just all stop calling women
desserts for a while uh if you must call
a woman a dessert at least pick like a
cool dessert you know like bear claw
what a bear claw that's fine
all right get back in the huddle there's
more shit to do
okay i think for a while we need to stop
yelling at guys when they drive by in a
sports car does anyone have that
girlfriend when a guy drives by a sports
car they go sorry about your dick
[Music]
how is that helping
you're making us look like hypocrites
right because if the roles were reversed
in that scenario it would be so messed
up right if a woman drove by in a sports
car and a guy was like sorry about your
giant pussy
not a good look